Queen Elsa might be a sweet and caring
ruler but she's arguably one of the most
dangerous characters in the Disney
Universe her powers are beyond control
but luckily her sister Anna is always
there to remind her that love will save
the day if you're like us you've
probably wondered how Elsa got her
powers in the first place
watch until the end to find out the
truth about the ice queen so winter
solstice Elsa's powers are a mystery but
that doesn't exactly mean that they're
unsolvable the oldest daughter of King
Agner and Queen Adina was allegedly born
with a gift that no one could explain
but when you take a look at her birthday
things start to make a little sense
Elsa was born during the winter solstice
which is known as the shortest day of
the year and according to Jennifer Lee
who was a screenwriter responsible for
disease frozen the princess was born
during a rare planetary alignment that
caused her to develop snowy abilities
Jennifer explained during an interview
with script notes that she went through
great lengths to explain Elsa's powers
throughout her first few drafts however
she soon realized that explaining them
took away from their originality
[Music]
so despite there being a valid reason
she chose to scrap the explanation
process originally Jennifer toyed with
the notion that Elsa was born with
powers due to being the thousandth child
born under the winter solstice this
caused her to be able to manipulate ice
with her fingertips but finding a
correlation between the planets the
Stars and the time of birth proved to be
a bit too technical so Elsa's powers
were simply put off as a gift so in
other words Elsa's powers derive from
her date and time of birth but
unfortunately this doesn't mean that
everyone born on December 21st is
automatically gifted Queen I do knows
family little is known about Queen I do
nuts past however we do know that she's
not related to Rapunzel by blood this is
made obvious by the fact that King
Gagner and Queen Ariana of Verona bear a
striking resemblance to one another so
we're inclined to believe that Agner and
Ariana are brother and sister but where
does this leave the Doudna and what
troubled past is she hiding disney gives
little to no information about i Dunas
pass however if we shift our focus to
the hit TV series once upon a time
things start to make a little sense she
goes by the name
of Gurda in this series and her family
tree is displayed for all to see so you
can imagine how shocked we were to find
out that Goethe's grandfather was named
king olav so here's our theory Olaf from
frozen is actually lsanty Anna's
great-grandfather could it be that King
Olaf was cursed by trolls causing his
soul to get trapped inside of a snowman
if so his essence might have
reincarnated itself into his great
grandfather's body so despite not having
any recollection of his past life he's
tied to Elsa in mysterious ways
so perhaps Olaf's biggest wish is to
shut his curse and return to his human
form but to do this a new Snow Queen had
to be born so could he have played a
hand in Elsa's mysterious powers we
think so the evil troll we're not used
to trolls being evil especially since
the trolls and frozen are sweeter than
sugar
however frozen is inspired by a fairy
tale called The Snow Queen
which has its fair share of evil trolls
the fairy tale was written by Hans
Christian Andersen and it was published
on December 21st 1844 and oddly enough
this publishing date is a mirror image
of Elsa's birthday in this tale we meet
an evil troll who uses his powers to
create a magic mirror but unlike the
magic mirror we see in Snow White
this mirror distorts everything it sees
in fact it can make a beautiful Oasis
look like a pile of garbage so the evil
troll tries to bring the mirror to
heaven with the intent of distorting
God's view unfortunately for him his
plans fail when the mirror laughs itself
out of his grasp and shatters on earth
and should someone come into contact
with it their hearts would turn to ice
so when a boy named Kai gets a shard in
his eye his heart freezes over and the
only one able to free him is his
soulmate Gerda after kissing him and
warming his heart the shard comes out of
his eye and they live happily ever after
could it be that Gerda is queen Adina
and kai is king Gagner if so perhaps his
frozen heart was not completely healed
and its iciness was passed down to their
first daughter Elsa the long-lost aunts
King Agner might have a sister but from
what we know
I dunno is an only child but after
taking a look at her family tree we
found out that she actually had two
sisters of her own again this
information was brought forward by the
TV series once upon a time so there
might be some differences between the
two bodies of work according to the
family tree she had two sisters Ingrid
and Helga however no one knew about them
because their memories were trapped
inside a crystal a Doudna who is
referred to as Gerda in this storyline
admits to having erased Ingrid and Helga
from arendelle history this action could
only be carried out by the trolls
themselves though so we see history
repeat itself here so why would Berta do
such a thing
well to protect her family mean of
course the deal the frozen entangled
movies tie into each other on more than
one account and this is only normal
considering that King Gagner and Queen
Ariana are brother and sister so could
it be that these siblings had a
recessive gene that caused their
offspring to be so sickly if so King
Agner might have resorted to the same
solution as King Frederick did when
Ariana was pregnant with Rapunzel she
fell ill and needed a magical golden
flower to nurse her back to hell and
although it saved both Ariana and
Rapunzel's life it also cursed Rapunzel
with a gift so are we the only ones who
think it's possible that Queen I Dunas
pregnancy also face some complications
because if it did King Agner might have
asked the trolls for help and being the
magical creatures that they are they
might have fashioned a silvery ice
flower for a Doudna to consume however
keeping this a secret was paramount
witches fire the trolls warned King
Gagner about keeping the flowers powers
to himself two years later when Elsa
accidentally struck Anna with Ice King
Agner knew to bring her to the trolls
and to make sure that he kept his secret
the trolls asked him about Elsa's powers
in front of his wife so in King Agner
revealed that Elsa was born with her
powers Iduna did not correct him the
troll knew that Agner could be trusted
Jack Frost's niece are we the only ones
who think that Jack Frost and Elsa bear
a striking resemblance to each other we
highly doubted there's a popular theory
floating around the internet that places
Jack Frost as Elsa and Anna's uncle and
although queen Adina might have a few
family trees circulating around this
theory is too good not to entertain so
to start things
we'd like to say that Jack's sister
remains pretty much nameless throughout
the entire movie sure she might be
referred to as Polly from time to time
but this is just a cute nickname that
her brother chooses to call her could it
be that flea and ADUN are the same
person
if so sleep might have fled to arendelle
after jack fell into the frozen lake
although there are some notable
differences between flee and Adina's
appearances
there are also some similarities first
off they both have brown hair side bangs
a round face a button nose and a dusting
of freckles however their eye colors
aren't the same a popular fan theory is
that fleas eyes changed from brown to
blue after searching for her brother in
the frozen lake if Jack Frost is in fact
queen of Dunas brother then this could
explain where Elsa's fair hair and
magical powers come from the prophecy
Elsa's powers might be extraordinary but
they were given to her for a reason
despite being a nice clean else's heart
is as warm as her heart is pure
but maybe she was born to carry out a
prophecy that was created long before
she was prophecies are often used to
explain why some characters are
incredibly special in fact even the
renowned writer JK Rowling used a
prophecy to explain why Lord Voldemort
wanted to murder a baby called Harry
Potter could it be that arendelle was
cursed to become the land of
never-ending winter if so it makes sense
that a baby would be born under the
winter solstice and hold powers that
were beyond her control despite being
born to create a never-ending winter
Elsa proposed her prophecy to save the
people she loves which isn't exactly an
easy thing to do what we do know however
is that the trolls know a little too
much about ice related powers in fact
they might even be living in arendale to
prevent the prophecy from coming true
when the king and queen of arendelle
sought grandpappies help
he knew Elsa by name despite never
having met her so we're inclined to
think that he warned her about fear with
the hopes of changing her faith the
Northern Lights
up next is a super interesting theory
that's brought to us by a youtuber named
Isaac he believes that Elsa's powers are
a direct result of her being born under
the Northern Lights in fact he also
believes that the trolls powers emanate
from this breathtaking phenomena since
the kingdom of Arundale is said to be
similar to Norway it makes sense that
the Northern Lights hang directly above
the castle
so perhaps Elsa's powers were given to
her by this mysterious force this makes
us wonder if her abilities grow weaker
the further she gets away from arendelle
but we'll have to wait to find out if
this is true or not the trolls powers
are said to correlate with the aurora
borealis so this might be why they're
able to counter Elsa's powers using
magic infused crystals I see DNA Elsa's
powers are a mystery and they very well
might always be in fact the only way to
confirm their source is by getting
Disney to come out with an official
statement but since that hasn't happened
yet we're left to state the obvious
Elsa's powers are genetic this is
somewhat proven by the fact that she was
born with them we all remember when Anna
was struck by Alice's powers but do you
recall the image King Agner saw while
flipping through an old book in the
royal library this mysterious image
showcased a well-dressed man lying on
his back behind him was a troll who
appeared to be pulling the cold air out
of his body so with this in mind some
fans believe that AG nars ancestor was
struck by the Northern Lights causing
his heart to grow cold and while the
trolls did everything they could to
rescue him they failed to extract the
imprint the phenomena left behind
this caused Elsa's ancestor to harness
ice in his DNA and generations later
Elsa managed to carry the rare gene
turning her into an ice wielding
princess this theory shed some light on
why Elsa has powers in Anna dozen so
there you have it guys the truth about
Elsa's ice powers before you go let us
know which theory makes the most sense
to you or better yet let us know if you
have some theories of your own and
that's a wrap don't forget to subscribe
to two things to be the first in line to
watch our newest videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]